condemnations and calls for an
investigation into the death of al
jazeera's shireen abu aklay came quickly
at the united nations from top u.n
officials as well as member nations and
the league of arab states that we look
at this as
one further step of the escalation of
situation that is happening by the
israeli authorities and that started
during the month of ramadan so this is
not only an attack on a person
whether palestinian or not but it is
an attack on the freedom of the press
and the freedom of
opinion
the u.s ambassador to the united nations
called her death horrifying she was
very well respected i actually had the
opportunity to meet with her when i was
in
the west bank
last november and
she did an extraordinary interview and i
left
there feeling extraordinary respect for
her so i know that she will be sadly
missed
by all of us and we have to ensure
that we get to the bottom of her of her
killing
linda thomas greenfield called on israel
and the palestinian authority to conduct
a joint investigation an idea echoed by
israel's ambassador but refused by
palestinians we reject
the claims of israel that they can do
a credible investigation they are the
criminals and the criminals cannot
investigate themselves
the palestinian ambassador called for an
independent international investigation
pointing out in a letter to the security
council that 40 palestinian journalists
have been killed since the year 2000
with no accountability
the arab league also called for action
on the part of the security council and
a resumption of the peace process
warning that if world powers don't focus
on the region confrontations and misery
will continue
kristin salumi al jazeera the united
nations